christophe qu'est ce qui s'est passé
parce que vous aussi vous étiez sur le
plateau sur jeter son plateau exactement
avec mon ami qui était très sympa ce
qu'ils avaient pu rentrer sous la table
ce serait rentré sous la table ouais
même si honnêtement il ya un moment où
on perd le fil de cette histoire quand
dans la soirée on nous annonce qu'on
mène une perquisition au domicile du
type à qui il aurait volé le passeport
et qu'on nous dit la solution est là bas
est là il ya un truc est incohérent et
moi partir de ce moment-là je me dis y'a
un truc qui va pas je veux dire c'est la
solution delà de la sphère dupont de
ligonnès ne peut pas se trouver chez le
type à qui il aurait volé un passeport
c'est incohérent et à partir du moment
où cette incohérence fait florès et se
retrouve répéter la soirée 1 se trouve
là bas
sk quel moment là je me dis ça tient pas
debout et qui sait à quel moment vous
êtes dit et pas un moment aux collations
vous ai dit blagues jeux 23h 23h30 moi
je n'y crois plus du tout c'est vraiment
aux caisses qui leur adressent foot pas
je suis pas ces jeux fonctionne pas
comme ça avec une avec les affaires
criminelles parce que la vérité c'est
que pour traiter des choses criminelle
il faut aller dans le temps du crime en
gros faut trois quatre ans n'est ce pas
l'assuré c'est le temps du crime
ça ne saoule ça colle pas du tout autant
de l'information continue du tout du
tout du tout les gens se sont gaussés
toute la soirée parce que les enquêteurs
dont on disait qu'il partait pour
glasgow n'était pas arrivé enfin à des
policiers français ne débarque pas en
écosse comme ça faut nouer des
conventions alors on va voir des accords
etc
donc c'est normal que y met du temps les
là bas c'est normal qu'ils mettent du
temps à vérifier
une analyse adn ça prend 10 12 heures
c'est normal qu'ils mettent du temps et
vous avez été un des prisonniers
christophe a alerté tous tes vendredi
soir à dire attention je suis pas tout à
fait science c'est le matin à 7h45 à
regarder écoutez moi je crois qu'il faut
qu'on gagne la police y est certes mais
toi je ne suis pas policier et moi je
sais que l'histoire des du crime c'est
l'histoire de conneries qu'on a raconté
donc souvent et donc je laisse une case
attendons ayant la patience d'attendre
quelques-uns que l'adn quelques heures
que laden viennent confirmer qu'il
s'agit bien de xavier dupont de ligonnès
ceci étant posé si c'est lui alors
probablement at on affaire non pas au
plus grand psychopathe de l'histoire de
grimm m'aimait pas loin en tout cas de
histoire du crime récente alors on a vu
qu'à partir de 9h 49 samedi matin on
avait pu arrêter
xavier dupont de ligonnès mais un
inconnu car à force d'interroger des
voisins et avec les dernières
informations de la police
le truc le plus fou c'est qu'on n'osait
même pas imaginer tellement c'était
incroyable eh ben c'est arrivé là vient
le bouquet final la cerise sur le gâteau
le moment où les journalistes sont bien
obligés d'annoncer que l'homme qui a
enfin est arrêté après huit ans de
cavale l'homme dont il parle depuis tant
d'heures d'affilée
eh ben c'est pas du tout xavier dupont
de ligonnès nos regards et on rappelle
que vendredi soir pour les journalistes
c'était sur xavier dupont de ligonnès a
été arrêté on a retrouvé xavier dupont
de ligonnès
pourtant dès le lendemain non la
personne arrêtée à glasgow n'est pas
aviez dupont de ligonnès l'homme arrêté
est liée à glasgow en écosse n'est pas
xavier dupont de ligonnès il s'appelle
dit joâo il ya billy mail c'est d'en
décider
rien à voir donc avec cet os mokaba ce
n'est pas xavier dupont de ligonnès a
parlé l'information vient de tomber
source afp le mar et à glasgow n'est pas
dupont de ligonnès l'homme arrêté hier à
glasgow n'est pas xavier qui font de
ligonnès il ne s'agit pas de cet arrêté
hier après midi à glasgow n'est pas
xavier dupont de ligonnès alors il
s'agissait donc d'une fausse piste comme
il y en a déjà eu beaucoup dans cette
affaire en même temps pour confondre une
vie joao et xavier dupont de ligonnès il
faut que celui qui a donné l'alerté voit
très mal et en exclusivité voici celui
qui a confondu dijon et xavier dupont de
ligonnès
je
[Applaudissements]
dès qu'on la dise lâche moi mon pote tu
n'y as pas ce qu'est que j'adore on peut
pas il faut pas tout son rang vouloir
les pauvres s'affirme alors j'ai tout
jeté dedans moi j'en ai parlé toute la
journée j'ai l'idée riom d'allah et
higuain ne c'est pas salé on était tous
dedans mais est ce que c'est c'est c'est
incroyable ce médiatique et on est tous
heureusement on était tous dedans même
nous un génie la vérité on essaie de
tirer le fiasco parce qu'il ya la fausse
nouvelle
ouais moi je lis le parisien le
lendemain il y avait pas seulement la
fausse nouvelle il y avait tout le roman
ouais c'est à dire il y avait une
invention totale que le type était sous
surveillance de la police écossaise
depuis plusieurs semaines qu'ils
trouvaient louchant fascine sûr car rien
à voir mais moi ce qui m'a le plus
choqué c'est que même quand ça a été
révélé que ce n'était pas à lier dupont
de ligonnès ils ont continué à diffuser
les images de la maison du fameux joao
en donnant son nom
nathan donnant le nom de la ville du
mans sur le numéro nous misons moi j'ai
regardé longtemps le procès a duré au
moins deux trois artères que même
innocente et ils ont quand même jetés en
pâture
qu'est ce qu'ils regardent et justement
on vient de voir la tête du pauvre guide
joao qui a été dévoilée par tous le
pauvre nuit là rien de monde le gars
qu'il est à la retraite il part
tranquillement voir sa meuf en écosse
leclerc il est tranquille le gala à
glasgow et non seulement on prend pour
le mec le plus recherché de france mais
en plus on défonce sa maison par des
preuves a que cette année dupont de
ligonnès un skin tout le pays voit où il
habite doit son garage jardin sa boîte
aux lettres
c'est l'autre nom qu'on a entendu tout
week-end le gars tout week-end on a
entendu gi joe à regarder guillaume joao
10 joyeux joie on dit joao
ô joie ô guy joao guillaume joao le nom
d'emprunt pris part et xavier dupont de
ligonnès durant sa cavale
ouais en fait il aurait complètement
changé de physique en xavier dupont de
ligonnès physiquement on nous dit qu'il
serait assez méconnaissable par rapport
aux images qu'on avait de lui il y a
huit ans qu'il aurait donc voyager sous
une fausse identité et aurait subi une
transformation physique
voici en exclusivité après de nombreuses
chirurgies à quoi ressemblerait vous
aviez dupont de ligonnès coup c'est
incroyable c'est vrai jean michel maire
pour avoir travaillé assez longtemps la
presse écrite c'est la rencontre la plus
dramatique c'est qu'ils ont la formation
la pire des heures ils les informations
vers 20h et aboua journal the book vers
21h 22h au maximum donc on à la fois
amateurs on a plutôt vérifier on peut
pas passer l'information
enfin chercher toutes les agricultures
en avoir ils sont que j'ai titré le
lendemain de prendre un risque
considérable qu'on ne prendrait pas il y
avait le droit les magasins arrêtent et
on n'aurait pas faire elle avait une
manière de me faire interrogations
christophe qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ça vous si vous aviez été directeur une
réaction est ce que vous seriez jeter
sur l'information aussi on peut pas
changer le monde tel qu'il existe je
pense qu'on peut taper sur les infos les
chaînes d'information continue est assez
vain elles continueront de faire de
l'information est venue c'est leur adn
elles vont pas dire on a on nous dit
qu'on arrêtait xavier dupont de ligonnès
on va vérifier et d'ici trois quatre
heures quand on n'aura plus un port
reviendra vers vous ce système ne
fonctionne pas comme ça il est assez
vain de le critiquer comme ça je crois
que ce qui s'est passé dans la sphère
dupont de ligonnès ça s'appelle bêtement
prendre ses désirs pour des réalités
c est moi ce qui m'a frappé parce que je
l'avais vu en replay et isabelle qui
elle a certainement vu aussi le téléfilm
de tf1
trois semaines avant ils partaient d'une
hypothèse qu'il avait bâti sa vie pas
très loin de chez lui avec une autre
femme qu'il avait eu un autre enfant etc
on avait l'impression que c'était la
réalisation de la prophétie du téléfilm
de tf1 et je crois qu'il y avait en nous
une rationalité qui nous dit maintenant
ce type s'est suicidé et puis une folie
qui nous dit peut-être qu'il a
reconstruit une vie
et ce soir là le monde du journalisme a
choisi a fourni et alors qu'il aurait dû
freiner des quatre fers il s'est
embarqué là-dedans voilà alors juste
christophe hondelatte pourquoi avoir son
truc c'était gi joe est là mais là il ya
un truc qui qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pour que si on regarde il applique à un
passeport un outil peyron va au domicile
du type à qu'il a piqué son passeport et
à ce moment là il ya un rip âge qui
seraient les journalistes commencent à
dire vas en vérité ce type la selle
dupont de ligonnès est là il ya un truc
qui va plus et ça dès 22h30 22h45 on
l'entend et ça doit nous alerter
il ya un raisonnement fossé mais tout le
monde s'en fout alors les voisins
guîtres l'homme qui a été confondu avec
xavier dupont de ligonnès ont tout de
suite compris qu'il s'agissait d'une
énorme erreur car il connaît ce guide
depuis des années regardez c'est dans
cet avis tu regardes août spleen avec le
temps de regarder ce qui se passait chez
le voisin et j'ai là c'est là que j'ai
vu qu'ils avaient les la scientifique
était là qui est en train de fouiller
enfin tout ça quoi pour en découdre on
accuse l'autre en mari d'avoir tué
décimé une famille enfin c'est quelque
chose de terrible
je suis désolé vous voyez cette photo
sac ou même monté tout à l'heure on a
attendu ça devient n'importe quoi et les
fuites là bas les écossais ou du temps
en temps nos langues erreur c'est
évident qu'ils se plantent
lamentablement bassékou fin oui la
sphère la sphère du petit grégory que
vous avez fait lui aussi a généré 3000
articles en vingt ans la cette histoire
de l'arrestation dupont de ligonnès a
généré 3000 articles en quatre heures
et dire que c'est là où on voit la folie
je veux dire la course à l'info à tout
prix je dirais c'est une erreur je ne
suis pas d'accord avec vous je pense que
s'il avait parlé sur le ton de la
supposition disons on en reparlera à
minuit en attendant il ya d'autres temps
forts moi j'ai bossé à bfm je sais
comment ça va mal ça ne se pose pas le
souhaiter mais la réalité n'est pas
celle là
et moi je n'aime pas lutter contre
l'arrêté dire des yaka fokon il faudrait
qu'à bien faire ne soit pas bfm bfm et
bfm il ya des fans dans le monde entier
à la fonctionne tout seul on l'a
alors on apprend en premier puisque
c'était la course au scoop et les médias
relaient tous les informations directes
sont là vérifiez bien sûr on apprend en
premier que l'individu arrêté par la
police écossaise a été confondu par ses
empreintes digitales
certains médias parlent d'un changement
d'apparence impressionnant comme vous
l'avez mêmes qu'ils auraient subi des
opérations de chirurgie là franchement
il a vu que si la corde après selon des
informations du parisien confirmées par
rtl des perquisitions sont en cours
vendredi de 22h à zéro heure trente dans
les yvelines plus particulièrement dans
la commune de limay c'est à cette
adresse qui était domicilié guide joao
voilà et ensuite voilà alors regardez il
ya eu des tweets
seul le monde est prudent et ne fait pas
sa une sur xavier dupont de ligonnès
puisque ont toutes les unes regarder
toutes les unes le lendemain c'est
xavier dupont de ligonnès regarder one
entre émoi tout les regards démontrez
moi toutes les unes et le monde comme le
monde sort qu'à 14e ace et donc d'avoir
la bonne enfant est forcément leur effet
pas là donc tout le monde regarder
partout arrétez arrétez arrétez arrétez
regarder et il ya eu un détournement de
la une du parisien lieu un tweet
regarder qui a été fait du xavier dupont
de ligonnès regarder arrêté en fait
c'est pas lui pardon aux familles pour
tous voilà
12h15 il n'y a plus de doute donc
l'homme arrêté n'est pas xavier dupont
de ligonnès le parisien reconnaît s'être
trompé stéphane albouy le directeur de
la rédaction du parisien pression de ses
excuses voilà aux alentours de 14 heures
voilà et guides joao l'homme confondu
avec xavier dupont de ligonnès est
relâché et ne souhaite pas s'exprimer
dans les médias
est-ce que christophe hondelatte dit
john va va porter plainte est ce qu'il
va c'est une victime collatérale de
cette histoire malheureusement je crains
qu'on ne puisse rien pour lui
moi j'écoute en 96 aux états unis
j'avais il ya eu un attentat ou aux jeux
olympiques et il ya un pauvre type qui
était gardien dans le parc olympique
il s'est fait arrêter et j'ai débarqué
moi un petit joint aux français avec des
milliers de journalistes devant la
baraque de ce type là c'était un enfer
et puis c'était pas lui
ben je pense qu'ils voient là tant pis
pour lui je crois que malheureusement il
va falloir qu'il fasse avec si on voit
pas tellement
alors il est content champions à
s'excuser ou qui ont réagi il ya malik
bentalha aussi qui a cru reconnaître
aviez dupont de ligonnès regardez
regardez merci
xavier dupont de ligonnès
bada
ça vient aussi voilà on vous les montre
aussi une vidéo on a imaginé xavier
dupont de ligonnès au bout du monde en
train de vivre sa meilleure vie à
regarder pendant que voilà
[Musique]
alors je serais pris fin avec cette
histoire et razik à laval un bien
entendu et on en rigole parce que c'est
vrai qu'à beaucoup de gens ça c'est tous
les détournements qu'aux effets sur les
réseaux sociaux
la fausse information a énormément fait
réagir prix de 100 mille tweets et il ya
eu vraiment des tweets très drôle
regardez par exemple
l'homme arrêté n'est pas xavier dupont
de ligonnès l'einstein sociopathe de 22
ans
voilà xavier de ligonnès avait changé
d'apparence
suite à la faire franck leboeuf voilà
direct à 10 du prix du lait s'est
présenté lui-même au consulat français
de rio pour démentir son arrestation sa
scénographie arrestation de xavier
dupont de ligonnès par scotland yard
suite à une panne de ferries les
enquêteurs français se décide enfin de
regarder à ses côtés hier il accouche
aujourd'hui mais tellement d'autres à
voilà lé votre aussi serré la wii allait
y aller bien également merci c'est bon
sur est méconnaissable
regardez y en ad'autres alesi à les y
voilà
rosine 87 ans je n'ose plus sortir de
chez moi de peur que la police me
confonde avec xavier dupont de la je
vous ai concocté un petit jeu mais c'est
très dur bonne chance à tous jeunes et
syndicats
la sécurité à l'aéroport une petite
bouteille d'eau xavier dupont de
ligonnès bon ça n'a pas arrêté encore un
autre météo un peu parce que c'est vrai
que c'était voilà vous avez du pont de
grès aurait changé d'apparence ses
services
la nouvelle il ya là dedans siri dial il
ya là dedans je pense la trace aussi du
fait que avec les réseaux sociaux les
gens se sont attribués les histoires
c'est à dire qu'ils se sont attribués de
xavier dupont de ligonnès le droit d'en
rire parce qu'au final quand même
semaine cet homme a tué sa femme et ses
quatre enfants à ces s'applique
normalement ne droit ne doit jamais
donné lieu à rire exactement
voilà et c'est un peu la même chose avec
nordahl le landais c'est un affaires
criminelles que les gens se sont
attribués pour tirer des plans sur la
comète pour l'attaquant machines et les
choses alors que là la sagesse demande
dans la sphère le landais comme dans la
sphère dupont de ligonnès d'attendre que
la vérité judiciaire est maire alors moi
aussi j'ai fait quelques tweets un bien
entendu samedi j'étais dans l'ambiance
voilà non mais voilà ils ont mis à
tomber dans le désordre on comprend plus
rien merci à vous hop voilà voilà mais
c'est bon mais tu vois là on voit
l'algérie
c'est une question qui se pose est
est-ce que vous pensez que xavier dupont
de ligonnès est toujours vivant je ne
pense rien
je m'interdis de penser moi je regarde
les faits est ce que je pense n'a aucun
intérêt savane et si les gens me
demandaient ce que vous pensez que
bernard laroche a tué grégory moi ça
m'intéresse pas de répondre à cette
question
voilà donc je n'en sais rien a tué sur
mission je n'ai aucune intuition il ya
une logique dans la préparation la des
meurtres qu'il a commis qui suggère
qu'il a pu organiser la suite d'accord
il a préparé des choses acheté de la
chaux acheter des sacs acheter une bâche
accès que faire donc ça ça suggère qu'il
avait une idée assez précise de ce qu'il
allait faire
après mais ce qui s'est passé dans la
tête de ce type qui manifestement est un
psychopathe
lorsqu'il a eu tué sa femme ses trois
premiers enfants qui l'attend 24 heures
pour tous et le 4e rennes ce qui est
quand même le fait venir en lui disant
maman 22 boire bien sûr bon après ce qui
s'est passé dans la tête de ce type là
pardon mais je suis pas je sais pas très
bien on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs weeks final ça oui mais
moi je vais pas dire il ya plein de
journalistes qui sont excusés l'époque
tous ont dit voilà on est désolé tout ça
en lisant ça arrive voilà de se tromper
puis on a d'autres qui sont excusés un
peu tard et voilà mais bon ça aussi ça
arrive aussi
non mais ça ils ont pas aussi en forme à
ce fait attention vérifiez généreux non
mais oui mais en ce moment c'est vrai
que c'est n'importe quoi c'est la course
au scoop on lit tout et n'importe quoi
même dans des shows nos très sérieux
enfin qu'ils étaient sérieux donc faites
attention c'est pour vous qu'on dit ça
parce que c'est vous que des vous
discréditer en faisant ça de plus en
plus et les gens et je vous dise le sens
de plus en plus les téléspectateurs et
les lélés voilà les gens ne me croient
plus et vous fait beaucoup de mal aux
journalistes qui font leur travail et
ils sont 88 95 % à très bien faire leur
travail
et forcément voir finale en faisant ça
moi j'ai une pensée quand même pour les
collègues qui ont dû gérer tout ça à
chaud et bien sûr les hommes
dominique rizet soit subie et puis
decugis ce du parisien qui est un très
très bon faits divers ces bons qui se
plante ça peut arriver à atteindre les
conséquences sont astronomiques mais
voilà on a droit à l'erreur